[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing harry potter games more
specifically i'm going to be addressing
the trailer released for a brand new
harry potter game that was recently
announced as well as providing you all
with an update on the much anticipated
release of hogwarts legacy you would
think that with the release of hogwarts
legacy being postponed that all hands
would be on deck warner bros when it
came to releasing the much-awaited pc
console game hogwarts legacy was first
announced one year ago today on
september 16 2020 when playstation
dropped the video on their youtube
channel the trailer sparked massive
interest almost instantaneously and to
date it has amassed over 24 million
views i think it's safe to say that this
is the game that fans want but much to
the dismay of fans the game was pushed
back so what's happening with it and
more importantly why is another new game
now being marketed more heavily than
hogwarts legacy the new game in question
is called harry potter magic awakened
which is a mobile harry potter game
admittedly the game looks pretty cool
and i certainly appreciate the aesthetic
they're going for but i am more of a fan
of games that i can play on my pc or on
my consoles if you haven't heard of
magic awakened already then here's the
trailer
[Music]
oh
hmm
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
[Applause]
the setting of the game unlike hogwarts
legacy seems to be roughly during the
same time period that many of our
favorite characters exist in 10 years
after the battle of hogwarts which means
that players will be able to interact
with all sorts of familiar faces as far
as gameplay is concerned it appears that
magic awakened is going to be kind of
rpg card based combat style game
developers describe the setting as
follows ten years after harry potter's
legendary victory of a lord voldemort at
the battle of hogwarts a young
muggleborn receives an unexpected visit
from a giant of a man by the name of
rubius hagrid who has come to deliver
their letter of acceptance to attend
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry explain to them about the
existence of the wizarding world and to
escort them to diagon alley to purchase
the necessary supplies for their first
year upon arriving however a mystery
begins to unfold on the grounds when one
of the first years ivy warrington goes
mysteriously missing during the sorting
ceremony and the player has to help find
her additionally the developers have
described the gameplay as follows
players will be able to customize their
character select their hogwarts house
attend lessons explore hogwarts and join
the dueling club as a player grows they
will learn new spells make new friends
and use their knowledge of magic to
design unique strategies and spell
combinations in a card based combat
system honestly it sounds pretty fun and
i'm definitely going to be checking it
out once it's released in the americas
the game which was developed under the
port key games umbrella was first
announced at the end of october 2019
it's actually already been released in
mainland china and taiwan thailand
malaysia singapore indonesia japan south
korea and the philippines should see the
game sometime this winter as for the
americas we still don't have a
definitive release date but now let's
talk about hogwarts legacy what's going
on with it what is it hogwarts legacy is
a multi-platform harry potter rpg in
which players will experience life as a
student at hogwarts school of witchcraft
and wizardry in a way that we've never
seen before the game doesn't follow the
traditional harry potter story in fact
it takes place in the 1800s over 100
years before the boy who lived ever
steps foot into its hallways port key
games from warner bros games is the
game's label dedicated to creating new
experiences to place the player at the
center of their own adventure inspired
by jk rowling's original stories portkey
games offers players the opportunity to
make their own narrative choices and
engage with the wizarding world setting
to discover new and unique experiences
the label was created to bring gamers
and fans new gaming experiences that
allowed them to delve into the wizarding
world in immersive ways where they can
create their own magical stories as it
was first announced a year ago many were
anticipating the game would be released
in 2021 but unfortunately it ended up
being pushed back to 2022. this was a
bit of a disappointment however as it
turns out this was done for all the
right reasons in the past we've had a
lot of harry potter games some good some
bad and some awful in this case i think
that warden bros are showing that
they've learned from their mistakes that
they want to create a perfect final
product something that they can be proud
of and something that fans can truly
appreciate game developers tweeted the
following creating the best possible
experience for all the wizarding world
and gaming fans is paramount to us so
we're giving the game the time it needs
and this is certainly something that i
can appreciate also as far as developing
both games is concerned warner bros is
of course a massive company
so i'm sure they have the bandwidth to
develop both games at once without
causing any kind of unnecessary
interruptions hogwarts legacy is still
set to be released sometime in 2022 we
don't have any information yet with
regards to a definitive or ballpark
release date and that's it for this
video are you excited for hogwarts magic
awakened how about hogwarts legacy
comment down below also if you enjoy the
content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
quick notice if you went away i'm silas
i've started a mythology channel so if
you like mythology and want extra
content from me then go and check it out
you